welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and this is a breakdown of peacemaker
episode six moon after reading so let's
just go on ahead and dive into all those
fun little details and things that you
missed in this incredible new episode of
peacemaker by nerd babies because my god
did things go really bad for christopher
and of course right off the bat we start
off with the same cliffhanger imagery of
mirn chasing leota that james gunn left
us dangling with for a week not very
nice though it seems last week mern
telling yoda to stop before the close-up
shot of her putting her arm up was
omitted to sort of build up the
cliff-hangery suspense for this week's
episode
stop
and then we finally get a reason why
harcourt and mirn had that weird moment
towards the end of episode 5 when mirn
asks harcourt if they're cool when
harker reveals that she figured out that
murren was a butterfly after mirn taking
a bomb to the face in episode 3 which
makes sense in retrospect because lyoto
and harcourt were somehow more frazzled
and shaken after the explosion than mirn
was who being an alien insect piloting a
human meat neck merely just gave them a
comical thumbs up which is a clear red
flag to harcourt who just helped adebayo
off the ground and of course the
episode's title mirn after reading
evokes the common espionage concept of
burn after reading as this crew one by
one has learned mirn's secret but we're
encouraged to actually read mirn not
judge this book by his cover since he's
more complex and morally empathetic than
his other butterflies so empathetic and
sensitive that they kicked him out which
is messed up and i really do enjoy how
james gunn is continuing leota's journey
into slowly becoming like her mother
amanda waller by slowly having leota the
newbie flip the script and interrogate
the most mysterious mass murder on task
force x autobio's come a long way and
actually this interrogation has the most
emotional facial expression that we've
seen from mern yet which is in line with
what mirn told economos about slowly
growing as a human based individual in
episode three now i'm becoming a deeper
more well-rounded individual in fact i'm
a little chilly right now you are no but
i saw it as an opportunity for growth to
say i was and with the knowledge that
myrn was kicked out of his group of
hidden secret adventured butterflies for
being too sensitive i'm inclined to
believe in mirn's good intentions for
humanity because of those you know
really nice moments of vulnerability
that he shared with an economos who was
in clear the nile that merni is a
butterfly in the first place and when
mirn says this i needed to stop them so
i inhabited the worst person i could
find this man leota he's
he's a murderer i took his freedom and
his face
he also sounds a lot like amanda waller
due to that being the one thing that
waller does best with task force x
taking the freedom away from only the
worst of society and then eventually
taking their faces away with a bomb and
if the person that mirn used to be was
anything like his old sociopathic
partner lock in the post-credit deleted
scene of this episode i'm glad that mirn
was possessed by a butterfly because god
he would be a terrible terrible man
[Music]
does this look sad but though he is a
sociopath i do appreciate the hamburglar
reference though because i'm a child of
the 90s and i think that james gunn just
really has a thing for mcdonald's
mascots with peter quill hilariously
calling thanos grimace in infinity war
let her go grimace so you've heard us
talk about how helix mattresses are
customized to fit your specific sleep
needs well helix also makes awesome
customized furniture under the brand all
form all form lets you personalize a
sofa using premium materials at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores customize your sofa to your place
and style by picking from over 500
unique combinations and blow your
friends and family's minds with your
custom designs and yes cousin jeff i did
pick out the color of the sofa's legs
and no i don't want to talk about
politics with you pass the salsa new
rockstars editor john got a brown
leather armchair and ottoman from all
form and absolutely loves them
comfortable and stylish just like john
that's a nice chair all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home and fast
free shipping and because all form ships
direct to consumer they're able to use
really premium materials at a reasonable
price for you and you get 100 days to
decide if you want to keep it if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a full refund and they
even offer a forever warranty so to pick
up your perfect sofa check out
allform.comrockstars all form is
offering 20 off all orders for our
audience at allforum.com new rockstars
all four it's for you but we then see
uncle peacemaker at the school of the
child of the hospital janitor jameel
from the very beginning of the series
being the amazing role model that he is
to the youths by of course telling them
the story of the superhero debut fight
with kite man that episode 5's newspaper
clipping teased but here we learned what
caused those series of blasts coming
from the intersection of meadow and
second it was the desert kind of eagerly
and that's how i defeated kite man
one of the world's most dangerous
villains with only my two fists my
desert eagle and two rocket launchers
then the kid with the sad eyes mentions
the black heart ruby which of course
could be a nod to james gunn's super
close friend and all around fantastic
actor man stephen blackheart who of
course provided the voices to charlie
the gorilla in monkey dory and is a
great friend that james gunn just likes
to include in his projects like he was
the nowhere dispatcher in guardians of
the galaxy one and then the kid with the
glasses asks him if he has a coterie of
super villains which is of course a
hilarious callback to racist auggie's
nosey neighbor from episode four do you
have a curry of super villains but that
is oddly suspicious to be for a mere
child to use the very adult phrase
coterie of super villains could this
child and auggie's neighbor be the
infamous 5th dimensional batmite in
disguise i only say this because in the
very next shot we see the words know
your neighbor written on a poster in the
wide shot of the classroom which could
be a nod to that potential connection
but it also could just be representative
of task force x's becoming familiar with
earth's planetary neighbors in the past
but scanning the classroom we can also
see imagery of a beehive placed above
peacemaker's head possibly to represent
the hive of butterflies of the series
and a protect the eagles display to the
right behind jameela janitor and his
wife a gender-bent version of mad
magazine's alfred e newman wearing a
flash shirt and white steve urkel shout
out flash and wonder woman respectively
and when mentioning wonder woman
peacemaker lies about them i effin
across the room which is a reference to
batman and wonder woman's first meeting
in batman be superman and there's also
some really goofy things written on the
chalkboard like the word of the day
being moistly and nonsense prompts like
what's your favorite shape and what
animal is in that shape then after
peacemaker safely dodges child support
phew james gunn's love of raccoons
shines through through jameel's
reference of the south american kawati
an animal from the raccoon family which
i thought was a really nice touch given
you know rocket raccoon and then
vigilante comes by peacemaker and insect
queen goff's place and drops a lovely
piece of wisdom to cut it out with the
introspection the mind is a den of
scorpions better left running from not
towards which explains a lot about
adrian's complete lack of humanity
because he literally is incapable of
considering how his actions affect other
people which is why it's so easy for him
to kill without remorse and why he has
no friends which one's me and which
one's eagerly the movies e.t and close
encounters of the third kind get
shoutouts while peacemaker and vigilante
ask goth a series of yes no and what's
your favorite color questions are you
here so you can place a shitty song like
in close encounters this particular
shitty song from close encounters to be
precise
and i cracked up when insect queen goth
tried to cover her ears when vigilante's
barbie girl by aqua ringtone played
because good god is that song
insufferable i'm sorry aqua you made
your money but at what cost and after
the police bust in to foolishly attempt
to arrest dc's maker of the peace
officer johnson the same police officer
with the charlie the gorilla black adam
newspaper from an earlier episode picks
up the diary that amanda waller's
daughter leota planted in peacemaker's
trailer and my god is it filled with the
ramblings of a crazy man who probably
watches too much fact attack you know
that weird alex jones parody for episode
one with weird talk about a new world
order through a secret totalitarian
government takeover and fears about
aliens crawling up his butt which of
course harkens back to economos's
hilarious graphic about how butterflies
could potentially crawl up your butt and
possess your mind and with amanda
waller's forger being the one who wrote
all of this crazy [ __ ] in the first
place it seems that waller was always
intending on pinning the murders of all
of these innocent butterflies peacemaker
killed on peacemaker in an attempt to
hide the secret of the butterflies to
the american public because apparently
task force x has been dealing with
extraterrestrial and extra dimensional
threats like starro mongal and batmite
for decades at this point with close to
zero awareness on the behalf of the
general public until basically the
arrival of superman in man of steel
because that's when everybody was like
oh my god are aliens real oh jesus
christ then of course [ __ ] hits the fan
and poor detective song is now the
avatar of the queen of the butterflies
with james gunn giving us one of the
most graphic scenes in all of dceu
history with the police station invasion
of the body snatchers with the invasion
ending with the police officers and
prisoners walking out together united as
one butterfly army which actually could
symbolize queen butterfly song's goal
for humanity basically for everybody on
the planet or at least all the main
leaders to be part of a united hive mind
to protect this planet earth from dying
like their old planet because let's face
it we're divided as f
and with the audience finding out goff's
queen status in this episode queen's
song might actually end up secretly
being dc eu's insect queen who debuted
in superman issue number 671 with a
yellow amber liquid called ambrosia
being fed to human bug hosts being a
central element to that story as well
and hey sorry to remind you about the
darkest chapter of that division but if
you think about it the butterfly queen
spending the last several episodes
imprisoned just to stage a violent
revolution when she overtakes the brown
shirted police authorities while
intercutting with the rise of white
supremacy all of these evil forces on
one side all of this parallels the rise
of adolf hitler from political prisoner
to conform his globe conqueror
empowering the most racist forces among
us and when peacemaker says he finds
asshat derogatory i felt so satisfied
seeing the results of james gunn's
twitter poll from september 2020 on the
proper spelling of asshat for a script
he was writing turns out he was talking
about writing this episode and finally
peacemaker plays us out with a lovely
piano rendition of motley crue's home
sweet home that mr piano john cena
actually played himself with his own
piano skills like he is an actual
trained pianist but anyways that is it
for this breakdown of this episode of
peacemaker what did you think what do
you think is gonna happen in this next
episode and like how do you think this
series is gonna end let us know in the
comment section below my nerd babies but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and of
course head to newrockstarsmerch.com so
you can get all cool peacemaker merch
all up on there because we got all the
coolest nerd [ __ ] baby i love you guys
so much and i cannot wait to see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you